I used to live my life a quarter mile at
a time but things changed our Father now
I will all this peace in your heart
little Brian I have a gift for you your
daddy gave me this no I'm gonna give it
to you it's very special it's for
protection from what's coming
all right down what's next no matter how
fast you walk
to be compared to you know not runs
their pastor
crying your vegetable coming in mine
just caught up to me there's a long time
down so we're up against a master thief
fasten high-performance driver
whoo easy
[Music]
Jacob is Tom's brother your whole life
you pushed yourself to be faster than
Donna smarter than down stronger than
time
but could you kill him
[Music]
because I'm ready if you are there's
nothing more powerful than the love of
family you turn that into anger there's
nothing more dangerous maybe this is the
end but we don't go out together you
know I'd ride to the death with you
[Music]
let's get to work
please tell me that's not a Pontiac
Fiero strapped to a rocket engine
impressive I no no no that's that's not
in for us
I came here to take you down a little
brother that's your mistake
this is my world
damn they got a magnet plane hold on
tell me you're not thinking what I think
you're thinking there's no bridge Oh
[Music]
hey guys surprise
nice Clubhouse
you